-Our first guest is
the director of the
National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease
and the chief medical advise
to the president.
Please welcome to the show
Dr. Anthony Fauci.
Thank you so much
for being here, Doctor.
-Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-Your office looks about
the way I expect it --
a lot of books.
Maybe a new addition is
the bobblehead there.
I'm assuming that was a gift
and you didn't have to
buy your own bobblehead?
-That's true. It was a gift.
-How do you -- Do you feel lik
they did a good job
depicting you in the bobblehead?
-Well, yeah, I guess so.
I mean, we're so immersed
in what we're doing,
I don't pay
that much attention to it,
but it looks pretty good.
-I guess I'd be pretty upset
if you were sending notes
back and forth to
the bobblehead people.
-Yeah, that wouldn't be good
-So, I have to ask --
it strikes me that the questio
that you probably get
asked the most
that maybe is
a little hard to answer
and maybe you don't like
having to answer is
people asking, "When are thing
going to back to normal?"
How do you respond when
you're asked that question now
-Well, you know,
you really can't give
a definitive answer
at all because there are
so many moving parts to this
There are so many
things in play.
We can say,
if you look at the fact
that we now have three
and soon to be more
highly efficacious vaccines,
that we really do see
the light at the end
of the tunnel.
I mean,
we still have the challeng
that we went way, way, way u
in a bad winter
and then we started to
come down precipitously.
But we are plateauing now at
around 50,000 cases a day.
We can't declare victory now
That would really be
ill-advised,
because we see
what happened in Europe.
They did the same thing.
They're generally
three to four weeks ahead of u
in the dynamics of the outbreak.
They went up,
started to come down.
They plateaued.
They pulled back on
the public-health measures
and now they are rebounding.
We desperately have to
avoid that.
If we just keep pushing along,
vaccinating 2 million to
3 million people per day,
keep a lid on it,
keep the
public-health measures going
I think we're going to be
in good shape.
I think as the months go by --
April, May, June, July --
I think we're going to continu
to do better and better.
When you say "normal," Seth,
I'm not sure what you mean
It's not going to be exactly the
way it was before this happened,
but it's going to be
a heck of a lot better
as we approach the
late spring, early summer
and get into the fall.
I would say it was approaching
a degree of normality
as we get into the
late summer and early fall
-We talk about
public-health measures.
Of course,
that means things like masks
What is your response --
You must pass people
in the street or in public
that are not wearing masks
Do you say something?
Do they get
a dirty look from you?
-You know,
I don't do that, Seth,
because that, in some respects
would sort of be
futile to do that just get int
that kind of a hostile exchange.
But it really is
disturbing to me,
because I've been through
all of these phases
that we have been through,
like when we tried to
open up the economy last summer,
and then, all of a sudden,
everybody pulled back
on everything
and we had this big surge.
We know what happens --
First of all,
we understand the need
and the feeling that you
really want to get back normal
You want to put
these things behind you.
But if you do it prematurely
it's going to come back
to bite you.
We've seen that happen
multiple times in this country
and it's going on
right now in Europe.
So we've just got to
hang in there a bit longer
This is going do end.
We're not going to be
this way forever.
But if we pull back prematurely,
we're going to get into trouble.
-Obviously, one of
the problems here is,
a virus does not appreciat
what we've all gone throug
and the sacrifices we've made.
I think sometimes,
that's the way, as human beings,
we react to news that things
might get worse again.
Variants strikes me as something
that when we heard about it,
again, it's very natural
to think,
"I can't believe
there's something else."
But could you speak to
the seriousness
and maybe explain to peopl
who don't understand
exactly what variants are.
-Yeah, variants are
mutational changes in the viru
that make it
a little bit different.
Sometimes, it changes
the function of the virus,
makes it more easy to transmit
sometimes makes
it even more serious
when you get infected,
regardless of the illness.
The thing that
we worry about the most --
that it will essentially evade
the protection of the vaccine.
Right now, there's one variant
that originated in the U.K
They're given numbers
that people generally
don't need to understand.
This one is called 117.
It's starting to become dominant
in the United States.
Fortunately for us,
our vaccines seem to
protect pretty well against it
There's another variant that
originated in South Africa
and a version of which
is in Brazil
that's a little bit
more problematic,
which means that the antibodie
that the vaccines that
we all get --
those antibodies are diminishe
in their efficacy
when they confront
this particular variant,
so which means that
the efficacy of the vaccin
might diminish a bit,
which means we might have to
boost people either with
the original vaccine
or with a version of
the new vaccine.
We don't have to do
that yet, Seth,
and we may not have to do that
but you got to prepared,
because you have to take
the variant seriously.
I don't think they're
showstoppers for us.
I don't think they're going to
just diminish greatly
what we're doing, but we have to
pay attention to it.
-When a new variant turns up
do you ever say
to one of your colleagues,
"Could one of you
tell people this has happened?
Because I feel like I've given
so much bad news
over the last year.
I would love it to come
from somebody else."
-Yeah, you know, occasionally,
I feel that way,
but that's not going to be
in the cards for what I do
I have to be out there wit
the good news
and the bad news, unfortunately.
-You testified before
Congress today --
not for first time,
but for the first time
under the Biden administration
Did it feel
any different for you?
-No, it was about the same
I mean, it was -- When you get
these kinds of hearings,
for the most part,
they ask good questions abou
things that they want to know.
Occasionally,
depending upon the party,
somebody will get snippy and
want you to answer a question.
Like today, somebody said,
"A 'yes' or 'no'
answer to this,"
when there was no
"yes" or "no" answer.
"But we want
a 'yes' or 'no' answer."
So, you know, you sort of
play around with that
and circumvent it.
-I'm sure you're getting good at
that part of
the job, unfortunately.
Hey, we're going to be
right back.
I have a few more questions with
Dr. Anthony Fauci.